aquí tenemos algunos componentes para
beats y bot vamos a desarmar la lámpara
de toque para poder usar su estructura y
soportar los componentes de nuestra
beats y bot vamos a quitar los tornillos
y al desarmarla vemos que la base tiene
muchas características tanto para los
tornillos como para las baterías vamos a
ver si esto nos sirve para sostener
todos nuestros componentes colocamos
nuestros motores para ver si quedan en
el anillo podemos usar un material que
sea plano como esta hoja del excel para
sostener los diferentes componentes ya
que la base original tiene una
configuración que no está en el mejor
lugar para nuestra aplicación así que
usaremos como plantilla la pieza
original hacemos el trazo con el
marcador permanente usamos el examen
porque es un plástico muy durable y es
muy fácil de perforar con máquina o
taladro y también se ve bien ya que es
transparente y muy fuerte aquí tenemos
un mini taladro llamado rotos y bit que
es una máquina que nos permite cortar de
lado en un material viene con un
accesorio que podemos poner
en el cuello de arriba y ya que lo
quitamos podemos poner el accesorio que
nos permitirá hacer el corte del
material a cierta profundidad ajustamos
la altura para que solo sobresalga la
cantidad de la punta con la que queremos
cortar ya tenemos el accesorio colocado
en nuestro roto zip y está a la altura
que queremos vamos a poner nuestro
plástico a la orilla de la mesa ya que
lo tenemos asegurado y con una pulgada o
2.5 centímetros que sobresalga de la
mesa para que no se doble demasiado
cuando comencemos a cortarlo es
importante hacer esto solo si ya tienen
experiencia usando esta herramienta ya
que si no la saben usar puede ser muy
peligrosa
aquí cortamos una orilla y después
cortamos la otra orilla
luego rotamos el plástico y continuamos
haciendo esto es más fácil hacerlo si
tienen una sierra de vaivén o una sierra
caladora ya que pueden hacer el corte
continuo y no requiere de mayor esfuerzo
pero aquí solo teníamos el roto si pitt
y es lo que usamos en caso de que eso
también sea lo único que tengan no se
preocupen también lo podrán usar usamos
nuestra regla para medir 90 grados
primero la usamos para encontrar el
centro y ya que lo encontramos vamos a
hacer un agujero aquí lo que nos
permitirá a rotar sobre un punto
específico y después poder lijar el
borde de nuestro lexan en un círculo
exacto así que perforamos el centro para
que quepa el tornillo de nuestra máquina
pueden usar un clavo si no cuentan con
este taladro y quizá incluso el clavo
funcione mucho mejor para perforar el
centro
pero aquí usamos lo que tenemos
aquí recortamos un poco los bordes de
plástico que sobresalen y ahora voy a
fijar nuestra tabla que es solo un
pedazo de madera que tenemos por aquí y
medimos la distancia al centro desde la
orilla de la madera y vamos a
asegurarnos que cabe el tornillo de
nuestra máquina ahora ponemos encima
nuestro plástico y colocamos el tornillo
si tienen un clavo pueden clavarlo a
través del examen y después quitarla
cuando terminen aqui pusimos nuestro
afilador ponemos nuestro lexan justo
donde el borde toque al afilador a
podemos girarlo para quitar los
sobrantes en el borde y dejar bien
redondo el exxon aquí aceleramos el
vídeo ya que hacer esto tarda cinco o
seis minutos seguimos dándole vueltas
para seguir quitando todos los puntos
altos del borde y nos quede un buen y
suave borde redondo ya que terminamos
verificamos que efectivamente nos quede
algo perfectamente redondo y suave
quitamos el tornillo ponemos el plástico
en su lugar y parece que queda bien
chequen que los tornillos de la
van en las orillas por lo que debe
quedar bien redondo y sin bordes ahora
usamos una lima para terminar de limpiar
el borde empujamos la lima lejos de
nosotros y vamos girando el plástico
hasta quitar todos los sobrantes
ahora volvemos a colocar el plástico en
el anillo y con un plumón marcamos los
agujeros en donde van los tornillos del
anillo y la base que pasarán por el
lexan y como el material es transparente
podemos ver y marcar los agujeros de los
tornillos nuevamente sujetamos el examen
al borde de la mesa y usamos este mini
taladro para hacer los agujeros en el
examen aunque no es necesario usar este
taladro para que queden bien derechos
los agujeros ya que este material es muy
delgado lo que sí es importante es que
hagamos los agujeros exactamente sobre
las marcas de los tornillos de otra
manera no quedarán bien
y tomamos nuestro cutter para quitar el
exceso de plástico que quedó al hacer el
agujero y que esta pieza asiente bien
cuando le pongamos los tornillos pasamos
la punta de la navaja por el agujero y
la giramos y lo haremos en ambos lados
para todos los agujeros aquí nuevamente
así dejamos el vídeo para que puedan ver
toda la acción ahora tomamos nuestros
tornillos y los colocamos en su lugar
esta es una etapa crítica ya que la
estructura de poliestireno es muy suave
por lo que debemos poner los tornillos
con suavidad de otra manera dañaremos
las roscas y los tornillos no tendrán de
donde sostenerse ahora ya tenemos lista
la cubierta y vamos a construir la
montura para nuestras ruedas